hello everybody and welcome back to
let's play dead space - okay we just got
back from an action-packed adventure
from space and we landed in these
apartments and there are two doors and
I'm gonna go through this one first
unless I already have it I don't think
have I I don't know I probably have I
don't remember what happened last yeah I
needed to find a store that's what
happened
sorry I missed this so it was totally
worth coming back right right right
Bueller who want what what the hell door
fu ha oh yeah oh god did I do that
oh yeah that's right oh yeah I was oh I
stopped it in here okay well I'm stupid
apparently yeah the creepy girl and that
guy who's shaking
okay yeah now that we're officially
caught up I'm a giant idiot
oh yeah give me that Wow could that be
any creepier yeah here take yeah oh okay
don't trust you now what else if we got
here huh
I heard body shut up shut up shut up
okay
Oh God [ __ ] you alarm what the hell
I wasn't even no one even really
startling it was like an armed man lots
of candles really but all these candles
come I think this is a fire hazard to
say it
Hey hey Billy
I remember the machine free with the
step for step sessions uh-huh
you're lucky you don't remember when you
do he starts coming back
who's he Billy who comes back what are
you doing Ross don't follow he's not
really there
yeah Isaac you know all about being
crazy don't you don't you buddy
okay rock down here Boop well that huh
huh No
ha ha naina behind me I thought somebody
squads ordered to fall back of course
endgame is influenced and contingencies
are in place
where's that body still twitching ah
shut up same station Pano's there was a
save station just up there nothing
happened in between you two unless I
missed something and something was
supposed to come out and scare me wait
this looks exactly like the same place I
was isn't it this totally is that's
that's the entrance to the church this
is exactly where I was why did I go in a
big circle
Goody's Anya nope
real people don't never have goodies I
got a stick spear sword thing ha ha what
the hell would you cover up what legs
gone and there you go
ah give me that yeah my inventory full I
needed to use one in English is that it
no arms gone gone what the hell you're
gonna be gone huh
anyone else how are you gonna take that
where these guys coming from
reload man now I need to use that health
pack
what music wow ah we're gonna now I
refuse go hey go there go n ho ho stompy
Wow die
what the hell where are these coming
from now come on now it is come from
everywhere and I used a pen Ivan and a
liner axe too slow Oh trying to lay out
some trap all right let's see one we get
in there a bit from behind me definitely
trap - why can't you turn sideways never
I'm not gonna complain well I'm gonna
complain a lot there
okay there's that 100 yeah ah he'll get
the torch oh okay that's that there's
the OP triggered one got you but another
one back whoops
whatever good enough they kind of lob in
a sort of oh that's not gonna hit him ah
not today not today
ah got ya you slow down and you get cut
to pieces it's more like it
behavin guys are behaving I see ya ha ha
I got you again but another one lay the
trap laid a trap ah
oh I missed ah god damn it how could you
get me a damn ah come on
get away get away get away get away
no no no no heel up how are you not dead
ah got you're not today
yeah and those mines were effective
Boop come on gimme gimme gimme
why you I can't have that one really
damn you
gives it off a pretty epic sound though
that net seem I beam like that would be
a warning to anyone who might be trapped
by that whatever okay there we go maybe
through that death job how am i doing on
one small one all you see it's dark
ah wait up [ __ ] can you come from
ah no not today
die die
you guys there we go I should just grown
stuff at you and I can I seriously not
get that one back now all right whatever
this game is rigged you load everything
everything's up full power oh here's a
store good good good come on
whatever whatever whatever I don't care
ah big deal to me okay whatever rivet
bolts I don't even have a rivet gun but
I might try it see your shells I don't
have a secret shell and I don't have
river I don't have pulse rounds I need
ammo for the flamethrower I don't even
really like the flamethrower
so I said he was gonna eat my face off
if I ever got the pulse rifle again whoa
watch out we got a badass over here but
I won't cuz I overused in the other cam
I understand but I do want to try the
rivet gun
let's give it a try lick of the rivet
gun try let's move this for now I like
the pain and um seat here ready a
terrific gun not that I can see what
about the javelin someone said someone
mentioned that it was cheap that I was
able to get the free guns so I
understand that so I'm gonna buy this
gun javelin sound like sounds pretty
cool
it's like telekinesis except on demand
alright do I have a javelin Spike's
there there Cap'n Speirs go baby go
there Go Go yeah alright that's probably
way too much ammo
okay so we're set right I got ammo for
the plasma energy line racks couple
detonators like at ease more detonators
now I don't use enough of them anyway so
alright let's give this javelin spear
thrower a try huh yeah five bullets and
I bought it with my own money
we cool fine what the hell was that
senex okay whoa [ __ ] okay I get it away
from you there we go
ah that killed you what you just threw
it into yourself just let it kill that
one well this is easy easy one over
there Wow once that one doesn't pose me
any danger anyway what the hell oh hey
look at that table clothes powerful yes
detonators love me so ha ha see another
one ah there we go
looks like looks like those things blew
up some of the Necromorphs as well I
guess they are kind of indiscriminate
well paranoid room one thing save you
should I just stand right next to one I
think is I think I did yep there it is
can't catch them hey I just saved so let
me try this guy yeah ha ha whoa yeah
oh so no bad ass who's look at that
sparkly that's that's the job on that
you ready you are ugly Oh looky you
still ugly even got eyes still in your
head you're ugly
it's called rubbing salt in the wound
burn out oh let me in just worth it
Ruby there we go bronze only a thousand
but whatever all right that's more like
it
and where was a store any did I need to
hit the stores right back here right oh
I'm so out of shape
Oh yep ah what the hell was that
yep it's awesome
they must be talking about me I'm not in
it yes right down here okay good good
good good good good good
goody goody goody yay okay let's he put
one of these in storage cell DS off oh
yeah I'm trying to play as legitimately
as I can't guys so but I don't know why
it dumped me with all of this so nothing
I could do about that what did I come
for I came for something
oh yeah pyranose because the workbench
was right there
yeah have a nice day I think a will what
was that nothing
Wow it is dark ah oh you gonna catch you
bring it ran ran ran oh no I'm gonna
risk I I'd be stupid I'd be totally
stupid and actually I'm just about to
run out of time here so let me just look
in the bench real quick and then all
actually yeah that's all the time I got
for this episode thank you guys so much
for watching as always I appreciate
every single one of you and as always I
will see you in the next part bye-bye